good morning good morning good morning
and welcome to the view we
are back live for season 5000
of the view congrats on season 24
thank you is that what it is it's season
24
apparently and you're the longest
running co-host there on the show these
days
well it's a long run i mean you know i
always say that longevity is
the most important thing in this
industry because most people don't last
that long
and i'm very grateful that i could and
so
uh now that we're in this election year
i feel that
the view is very important and in the
center of the discussion and so i'm
happy to be here
right now filming the show from home and
having to do this all virtually still
how's it going
sunny and i really miss the studio um we
obviously want to be safe and respectful
of the guidelines that are put into
place
by our government officials you know we
miss being at the table and we miss
having meetings in the morning and being
able to so much of tv is like getting
getting a vibe in the morning and and
throwing around ideas and getting
prepared like
i half the show happens before the show
actually airs so i miss that but i also
am really grateful that
um our show can continue being like
robust and compelling
being able to do it from home and via
satellite you know it's interesting
because i was worried about doing it
from home and you know we
we got these mugs save you from home and
i was like oh my goodness we're never
getting back into the studio right
but when you look at our ratings before
for the last eight weeks in season 23
we were number one out of all the shows
and
and i think that speaks to the fact that
um people
really like to just listen to us speak
to each other
about the hottest topics of the day and
and and that's where our sweet spot is
and we never
lose that because we're friends and not
only co-hosts and we're able to do that
and we all have really strong views
we're clearly very
opinionated women and you can't lose
that even if
you're at home how hesitant are you to
get back into the studio
personally for me there's no reason to
do it but if i have to i will
but i do enjoy rolling out of my bed
into this chair
doing the show and then rolling back
into bed i think that's a fabulous way
to
to be and it makes me calmer and sweet
and everything
if i had some calm and sweet where i
could go roll in and out of bed that
casually i would love to do that to get
calm and sweet i have to leave my house
because three people can't leave by
themselves and those are those babies
adorable but it's a lot so this is my
this is my calm place how does it feel
to be back
oh it feels wet thank you it honestly
it feels like home i've been a fan of
this show so sarah you're the only one
of the co-hosts that are holding things
down
in studio can't imagine how that's
feeling and of course it's at the same
time as you are making your return to
the view
so why did you want to come back to that
round table girl
who wouldn't want to come back to that
round table it was an honor the first
time it's like catching a shooting star
twice
i feel like this was such a gift for me
to sit next to these people when i got
the opportunity to leave i
i it was amazing but to leave the view i
had fallen in love with this place on so
many levels it wasn't just the people at
the table
but the job isn't the same so although
i'm glad that whoopi is rolling in and
out of her chair
i used to sit by her and i got some of
her best material
during commercial so i do feel i'm being
robbed of some of the promises of what
this show once was for me and what i'm
getting
hopefully you'll get the gals all back
together in the video soon
someday when it's safe and they're when
it's safe and we're all
safe together we can laugh again side by
side or i'll just show up at whoopi's
house
that's not beyond me either whoopi i
know it's been no secret that you have
struggled and battled pneumonia in the
past how have you been keeping
yourself safe and careful during this
time i have been in this room
since uh march in this very room
i have gone nowhere i have done nothing
would be in this room
well that's you gotta stay safe you know
um how has it
and i don't let anybody in the house
bro you got to do what you got to do
have you been staying safe and healthy
during this time
joy yes i'm very cautious i don't really
go
mingle with a lot of people i i haven't
gone to a restaurant
since february march i've been basically
in uh
quarantine for six months now right do
you feel like look you guys are having
to do
this show still virtually do you feel
like
the debates the conversations that
you're gonna have especially in regard
to it being an election
year and what's going on on the
political platform are you
the conversation is going to be able to
resonate considering they're being done
virtually now and the delays and things
like that
well it's the technology is difficult
it's hard it's harder for me
because i'm not um the kind of person
who takes the stage and then
pontificates
it's harder to have a conversation in
this format so i
i don't really like it because my style
is i'm a jabber
and then i want to say congratulations
to it's your pregnancy congratulations
yes thank you gosh how long am i i'm
like eight and a half months almost i'm
very close
um i feel like how all women feel like
i'm just feeling like
slow and big and tired and your back
hurts but
you know i'm gonna push through as long
as i can and uh
you know the show has been there i'm far
from the first pregnant woman that's
been on this show so
everybody's been really kind and really
amenable and it's funny it's the least
interesting thing i talk about all day
is being pregnant there's so much going
on in the world and it's been such a
chaotic time that
if i weren't getting you know gaining
weight and having all these changes in
my body i would probably forget about it
how have you navigated pregnancy during
this time especially
this isn't my favorite time in the world
in general and i think everybody feels
that no matter who you are if you're
pregnant not pregnant have kids don't
have kids everyone i know is um
going through a challenging time just
because you know we're in a time of such
social change social unrest divisiveness
the election
and i think everybody's i keep saying
we're just like white-knuckling it to
the election like that's how i feel it's
like everybody's just sort of like
bracing to see what happens and it's
sort of been
a blessing and a curse what you're gonna
be having a little boy little girl
i'm keeping it a secret until i know
what it is but i'm keeping it a secret
but i promise i'm very close so i
promise i'll let you know i'm not gonna
just not tell anyone
sonny we're gonna know soon all about
your new memoir honey because you've got
a new memoir coming out some juicy stuff
in there you're gonna give us some
behind-the-scenes looks
at your former gigs your former jobs and
of course
backstage of the view as well so what
are you most looking forward to reveal
to your hands
in your e-book the book primarily is
about identity
justice which has been a a big part of
my life of course
and and um i hope that it's aspirational
because people i think see me on the
show
and and they see my career and they
think oh my goodness this is this is
someone
who's made it but i come from really
humble beginnings i'm from the south
bronx projects and it's something that i
wasn't always proud of
but i'm very proud of it now because i
want people to know that if someone like
me
can be sitting here talking to you then
anyone can do it and and that's supposed
to be the promise of america i'm hopeful
um that that is the big takeaway that uh
we are a country
that um enables people like me
to succeed did you you know
express and share with your fellow
co-hosts what you were writing about
exactly in your book in regards to the
view i did megan is reading my book
right now
she's very honest and very raw i've
worked with you a long time and there
are stories i did not know
and they're not you know she does not
come from the same kind of background i
do
and it's incredible to see what an
inspiration
like you said not just the american
dream but all the things you've been
through to get to this point
and the stuff about the view is very
honest and it's very accurate
and i didn't sonny got hired in a
different way at a different time than i
did but
i think there are important
conversations to be had right now and i
think there's important reflection in
our culture and i think
it's very brave to write a book like
this while you're still on the show
which i have great respect for because a
lot of people wait till they leave
and i think it's i think it's going to
be really compelling for a lot of people
i think it's really important especially
right now just in the moment that we're
in i think there's a lot of
conversations especially about
you know identity that this sonny is an
afro-latina
and i think it's important to know that
you know in the book she explores
times when she's been you know treated
differently for that reason and i think
it's really important right now that we
reflect
on these kind of experiences and have
these kind of conversations so
it's really good one hot topic that we
are loving
over at et is that of carol baskin the
oh so controversial carol baskin she was
on the hit series for netflix called
tiger king and now she's been cast and
dancing with the stars so
what do you make of that casting
decision and will you be watching her
i don't watch dancing with the stars and
i don't watch the tiger king
if you knew what i watched you would not
even bother interviewing me
will you be watching i wish i could
watch anything in its entirety i don't
think to just hit the bare minimum in a
day
yeah right now i long for a full episode
of anything
so right now i would say just due to
time restraints
um i have not gotten a chance but i was
a tiger king fan i will say that
what do you guys make of the casting and
will you be watching
she's an alleged murderer so you know
that's awkward
[Laughter]
i thought she fed her husband to a tiger
so
i mean you know what i'm really looking
forward to christelle
from selling sunset uh being on so
that's who i'm rooting for but it's
definitely an interesting casting having
carol baskin on i'm like a former
federal prosecutor
i don't really know how i feel about get
ready you cool cats and kittens right
what about you whoopee
no i won't watch i don't i never watch
i don't watch television actually the
only thing i'm watching right now is
cobra kai
that's what i watch oh yes you think it
is you know you think
really this is you're really doing and
yes i really was watching it and had a
great time
it was so nice to get something
positive it was great well you know
we gathered a lot of positivity from
chadwick boseman
unfortunately he passed in time recently
you all mentioned him
today in your uh season kickoff of the
view when he was 43
after fighting a very private battle
with colon cancer
and uh it was really sort of
shocking well you've been very vocal
about lobbying disney for
making a wakanda park why do you think
this is so important for disney to do
this
and have you received any sort of
response from them um
no but i think it's important because
disney uh should be the spearhead
that shows what uh being interested
in other groups can be like they have
this
marvelous opportunity to create wakanda
they have this
marvelous opportunity for little girls
not only to be princesses
but they can be warriors as well uh the
black panthers ears can be
synonymous with mickey's ears they can
open the
wakanda the disney wakanda hotel
you know there are so many things that
you could do
that would be meaningful and i think
revive
the brand in a way that it hasn't had
for a while
and really put a nail in the coffin of
the idea that disney and black people
don't go together
i think we should have you to be the
head of that committee oh she will be
you don't open wakanda without whoopee
exactly
well i will have and don't forget this
his statue you know should be when you
come
in you know when you get on the
spaceship and the doors open and
you're in wakanda his his statue
the princess statue should be there to
greet you
you posted a beautiful tribute to
chadwick boseman on instagram
what is the legacy he was so thoughtful
and i had no idea that he was suffering
in the way that he was suffering and
what
he gave to the african-american
community in particular
was that he showed us what
an african king looked like that type of
excellence
right and i saw little kids wearing
king t'challa outfits i took my son to
the premiere
and he left with tears in his eyes and i
think that will be his legacy
that he embodied this black excellence
and all of these characters jackie
robinson
king t'challa thurgood marshall i just
think we'll
forever give black boys and girls
um that that embodiment
and it's just something that we don't
have we we we didn't have that
representation in the media and it's so
very very important and i'm i'm just
forever grateful
for that it's just gone so soon and um
to champion on through that it's just
incredible
it's really truly incredible my husband
described it as this generation
superman dying and i think it's accurate
it's like
this version of christopher reeves
because again you just see
children all the time not just on
halloween but dressed up like
black panther dressed up like characters
and it's unbelievably tragic and sad and
i hope that
disney continues to honor him and i know
they will